[Music]
it's day two now of the strike by TV and
film writers demanding higher wages and
they are picketing outside some
prominent Studios across the country
including our parent company that would
be Paramount the stakes are big huge for
the future of entertainment and many
shows have already been knocked off the
air Elise Preston has more now from Los
Angeles
what do we want
outside Production Studios across the
country
thousands of writers have stepped away
from their keyboards to form picket
lines better pay better residuals uh
larger writers rooms
here in Los Angeles wga president
Meredith's team joined protesters
outside of Netflix Studios they need to
fix the model that they've broken and
until they do we're going to be here and
we're going to be on strike
on strike late night has taken the first
hit
daytime shows like cbs's the talk have
also gone dark and it's the same story
for soaps let her
get hurt among popular series showtimes
hit Yellow Jackets which is part of
Paramount has stopped working on its
third season
meanwhile HBO's House of the Dragon will
continue production on season two since
they tell variety that scripting is
already complete Cynthia Littleton is
the co-editor-in-chief of variety and
author of TV on strike she says a
prologue strike would mean writers lose
their jobs as Studio ship production to
unscripted content the studios are going
to lose a lot of money on having to
scramble they're going to have to shut
down shows that they thought they were
going to produce there is going to be
pain all around for CBS morning's Elise
Preston Los Angeles
so all the writers out there on behalf
of CBS mornings we say thank you